bismillah al hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
we greet you with the best of greetings
peace be unto you this is a greeting of
Jesus this is a greeting of Moses and
the last and final messenger sent to man
kind of Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him now all these messengers they came
with the same message they never called
people to worship themselves saints
angels nothing in creation but the one
god and they came with a complete system
a way to live your life not according to
your whims and desires but according to
how the crater wants you to live it'd
only be fair if he said a complete way
of life otherwise it'd be left for you
to figure it out he'd be making mistakes
here and there bumping into this and
that so God is the most just and he's
the guy so he hadn't sent the guidance
on this episode of the Dean show we're
going to talk about that complete
guidance and how it was implemented how
it was implement we're going to go a
little bit way back in history and
you're going to see when those who
submitted themselves the Muslims when
they implemented is slab and the law of
God Sharia Oh some people get a little
nervous here so you're going to learn
about what Sharia means and a practical
example of when it was implemented and
how wonderful things were and we come
back here on the Dean show Allah there's
only one way
is his messenger Allah like him
Allah there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger Allah no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice Salaam
alaikum peace be unto you they come set
on PC on th e or sheikh waleed yes how
are you I have the LA how are you good
I'm blood you don't shake believe the
Sunni of course the power 7 that first
love them so much yeah so tell us now
okay we have so little time but this is
a vast topic and at the end we're going
to direct people where they can go look
into it because you're actually teaching
a course on this Sharia this is
something a lot of the not yet Muslims
they hear this word they say we don't
want no Sharia over here they don't even
know what it means so let's start off
there before we get into our main topic
what does is worth Sharia me so they are
simply if we want to define it it's
Islamic Claude want to translate it this
way because it is a something it is law
that is decreed by God because when you
think about it God or Allah as we call
him he's the one who created human
beings and of course the one who creates
knows better about his creation than
anyone else and this is even if someone
invents something in this life they know
about it better than anyone else so the
one who created the human beings is the
one who knows what works best for them
and you said Allah so we're not talking
about a man invent anus or the moon
inventiveness we're talking about who
that creator of the universe and the
human beings and everything this is the
Islamic definition which is Nick means
the the law that is decreed by a lot to
the human beings and it's it's two parts
there's one the the law of worship there
is a lot of dealings mean the trading
the dealings when
beings deal with each other or do you
want anything else even nature anything
else there's a lot of governs the
Muslims and their life and this is the
ideal law that is Allah has told us
about and of course we have parts that
Allah has made our God has made that
that's the same it's fixed all it
doesn't change based on time and place
but then we have the other part which
it's flexible and people depending on
where they live and what time they live
in and where they are they could adapt
these laws to suit the environment that
they're in and an example for that if
you want to give me a give us an example
so let's talk about for example the laws
of trading so interest is something that
is fix is always wrong and it's always
forbidden Islam because it always leads
to a lot of destruction and we have seen
that we are actually witnessing this at
ours right now so yes when we saw the
recession and everything that no one
could argue about it anymore it might in
the beginning we make that some people
might get a game of it while other
people are losing but we could witness
what it causes to the worldwide economy
in general so that's something that is
always forbidden in any time in any
place but for example and the laws of
trading for example that there is a
flexibility for the currency we could
use gold and silver we could trade with
each other things directly we could use
paper money we could use checks Islam
here leaves things flexible so that
people could deal with whatever is
comfortable to them so we have part that
that doesn't change because there is
always a constant harm throughout
history and then we have the parts that
are flexible so that people could adapt
it based on where they live in
what type of it now that Jesus Moses
Abraham did they come with a Sharia also
of course yes now the all religions are
or the clearest religious they are
actually Islam which means the
submission to God because we believe we
as Muslims believe in all the previous
prophets that came before that were
mentioned in the Quran and hadith and of
course certain laws as we see are the
same in Islam as in other previous
religions but also there's laws that
have changed because human beings change
and we know this as a fact from
different time period so based on those
changes the law has changed but however
since Islam is the final religion or
what's Prophet Muhammad came with since
we said it's all Islam of Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him came with
then this was at this time this is the
final revelation of the religion that
would be followed to be in it so you
mentioned what the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon last and final mission to
mankind k but Islam but the Jesus Moses
they all did islam goodnight because
islam means to acquire peace by
submitting like you said to your will to
Gosnell that's correct the Crete there
are the belief doesn't change our belief
about God or belief about the angels our
belief about the messengers that part is
fixed among all the messengers the part
that change is the law because human
beings again and the environment and the
surroundings were different at the
previous messengers but since as long as
we said it's the final religion then
that part there was a part that is made
in the law fixed and part that is made
so just before we go on into our main
topic yes as we said all the messengers
came with the same message submit to the
One God worship the Creator not his
creation and do the good that God wants
you to do so you get to paradise so they
all came they were all Muslims because
the Muslim is one who submits two god
they all came with the Islam worshiping
submitting to one God and they all came
with Sharia God's long yes so now we're
going to go into a contrast before and
we're going to use one part history
people can go and look this up because
like I said most of the media are trying
to create a fear frenzy and they throw
out these Arabic words and they don't
even know what they mean yes and they
create the sensationalism and we hope
that the media and all those because we
care we share with them that they can
come to the Dean show and they can learn
about Islam so then we can all live in
peace because then this fear will be
eradicated because of your creating fear
then you know what people are obviously
not going to be more in tune to
collaborating working together and we
want to work together so we need the
proper education that's what we're
trying to do and sitting with scholars
such as yourself so then we can all come
to this proper understanding now we come
back you're going to talk to us about
Spain how's that that's excellent
marketing okay so we'll be right back
here on the Dean show to give you a
example of when God's law Islam was
implemented and how people were living
in peace from recommendation eastbourne
about 60 years ago in former Yugoslavia
base Bosnia ekta Second World War and
imagine today you have one child feel so
much it's important that we realize that
Islam is a gift so we believe that in
the teachings of Jesus what is left
there is truthfully I mean he's the but
the truth has been mixed up with
paganism and with nature worship and so
Islam has given you a pure
straightforward way of approaching
monotheism
ger shakily go ahead now we're back here
with you go ahead and take it away tato
but talk to us about Sharia and Islam
and when it was implemented in Spain
talk to us yes thank you I have a
pleasure to go to Spain this year and I
witnessed over there the Muslim heritage
and how this Spanish culture was
affected by his lab now if we want
because many people say okay so how did
the Muslims get there in the first place
and there's always this misconception
about the Muslims are trying to take
over the world or something that people
might be scared when they hear about
this term in the beginning but how did
it happen and also that Islam spread by
the sword and and all these
misconceptions but Spain or the history
of spain is the perfect example of how
that was not the case and the best way
to know this is to compare and contrast
between Spain before Islam and Spain
after it so we'll start with before
Islam yes so we'll start before Islam
now again some historians they call the
Muslims that they have occupied Spain
for example but why wouldn't they call
others other nations that came into
Spain before them this isola Spain and
there was people living there tens of
thousands of years ago of years ago and
then the Romans they took over the land
of Spain and then the visigothic kingdom
the Germanic tribes they came and took
over from the Romans after the around
the fifth century they took over and
then after that around the 8th century
in the year 711 specifically that's when
the Muslims King now what's happened and
how was it before and after so in order
to understand before the Muslims were
there in Spain there was a king called
Rodrigo and this king he was ruling
spain by force and by dictatorship so
people actually before Islam over there
they were paying so much taxes more
half of what they're making and we're
not just talking about just the the rich
or those who have businesses even the
poor were forced to pay that tax so they
were playing like thirty forty fifty
percent of their earnings yes more more
than that i chant it was taken to them
by force as sometimes whether they
worked or not yet at the same time also
there was a lot of spread among there
was a it was spread over there a lot of
evil so for example people were afraid
because there was forcible rape by the
soldiers were there soldiers were a
preview before his son that's before
Islam and there was chaos there was a
lot of stealing and there was a lot of
killing and this was all this is
documented II could check this even in
the non-muslim history books how Spain
was before Brian was at an all-time high
rape denigration of women subjugation of
women everything was just upside down
that's correct and we're going to see
this actually once the Muslim King how
people who were in Spain we acted to
when the Muslims king and and when the
Muslims they entered the country and
over there and King would read when he
was fighting in the north and he had to
some internal conflicts it won't move
through much but when he heard the
Muslims there and he came with his army
and the Muslims were outnumbered by 128
yet they were able to defeat that army
it was again and they weren't killing
civilians it was soldiers so it's just
right here you said okay so there was no
killing it was a complete constitution
Islam where there's no killing of
innocent women children none of this was
going on that's why the Muslims yes it
was soldiers against soldiers and that's
what happened now after that period the
actually some of the even was documented
that some of these soldiers because they
were forced to fight by the king Rodrigo
and they were not getting anything out
of it so and he could imagine and that
one evidence for this is even though
they were outnumbered by eighty one day
they were able to defeat them and after
that when the Muslims they went to the
to the towns and villages one by one
first of course when any new nation our
eyes people are afraid normally because
you're afraid of what you don't know
they're a little bit timid yes but when
they saw how the Muslims first of all
the people don't have to pay those huge
taxes and they'll cut out right away
that's completely cut out what they have
to pay that debt they have the choice
either they accept Islam and this is
done there is no compulsion or force in
the assassin will put a knife on your
neck as they accept Islam is this
allowed that never happened because it
happens in justice ever this is because
even when the muslims ruled spain for
800 years the Christians and the Jews
and other religions as well we're living
there and they existed there until
basically together peacefully to
Christians and you what I heard that
this was like a golden ages for the Jews
in Spain this is true that's correct
least that was the Golden Age and they
were protected by the Muslims but once
the Muslims were defeated and forced to
leave that's when the Inquisition
happened and they were killed and this
is a historical fact that we can't hide
they were killed in the Inquisition and
tortured by the Catholics for example so
the Catholics killed Muslims and the
Jewish and videos as well that was
Inquisition yes and at that time but
before I'm sorry before that Jews
Christians Muslims were living a piece
completely in peace and that's why we
saw even there's some scientists from
from Jewish people as well who floors
under the Enders empire yet again we
almost say Islam and practices a
tolerance without compromise of the of
the people or the religions was this
under Sharia law this was yes under
complete sorella so Wow so what's
happened is people there when they saw
how the Muslims were treating them very
nicely the soldiers there were
protecting these villages from they were
protecting
like acting like the police so peace
came back to these cities and villages
and at the same time those people
instead of paying is use taxes they only
had to pay if they don't want to accept
Islam let's go back into yes they had a
choice now they can accept Islam or they
won't be killed no now oh that's a nice
conception yes yeah the other option is
they paid just how much one gold coin a
year if they could have four what's this
call this they call it easy what does
this mean when it is that they get
nervous and scared about the GZA which
is actually a lot less than the 50 40 30
percent is that right of course if the
people of this is only for the working
people who could afford that they fear
if the people were sick if it was the
women if they were also the the senior
actually they get paid under Islamic law
they get paid if they have any needs and
no one is there to fulfill their needs
the the Muslim government would fulfill
those needs for them but this even that
gold coin was paid that whether they
indicated for their protection so
someone was gold and and and for example
and fight with the Muslims to protect
the nation he wouldn't have to paint
that book there was a story that I heard
have you collaborate on this where the
Muslims who were protecting the
Christians another group of Christians
came to fight the Christians and the
Muslims were defending the Christian
because they were living in paying this
tax to Josiah and they weren't able to
fight off the Christian army that was
coming to fight the Christian army so
they gave them to jinja back but they
tried humbly to defend them did you hear
cases like this yes and there's even
even in later in history that's happened
for example the later Ottoman Empire
they were protecting the the Netherlands
the Dutch people who were protesting
they were protecting the most of
protecting them from the Catholics yes
and there was actually an economic
relationship between them between the
and the Ottoman Empire so that's another
example in history that the Muslims they
in this case they protect the truth and
even we were just mentioning the what's
happened to the Jews know many people
don't know that when when they were
prosecuted in Spain who did they seek
refugee to at that time they start for
Fiji to the rising Ottoman Empire so the
Ottoman Empire the Muslims protected
them from what was happening to that
they put the Muslims were protecting the
Jews also yes this is null in history
yes you just got to do your homework yes
this is well but why is this false
information now spreading like Islam is
the enemy of everything everyone is slob
doesn't want peace Muslims are okay
they'll say Muslims are good people but
it's Islam you need to worry about why
do you think this is there's two things
we have to pay attention to first is
getting educated about Islamic Christian
in all history and the other thing is we
have to distinguish between Islam and
Muslims its line is the perfect religion
from God submission to the One God but
the muslims some of them are good some
of them are not following the religion
correctly some of them may do wrong
things but that should not as they say
don't judge the car by the driver you
can have the excellent car and a
reckless driver and if you want to test
really that card you should have a good
driver behind the wheel so we have to
always distinguish between the teachings
of the religion and what people are
practicing great so tell us now so the
tax was a limited this high tags are
still in the people now they go and make
so much money now they got to give half
of it or more to the king Islam comes
now the people can keep their money
they're paying what is this equipment to
the amount that you saw that they're
having to pay what is it a quote
associate athletics one gold coin right
now you know
how much of the ground with gold equals
right now and I'm not just read % 5% 2%
what is it equivalent you put a
percentage on in taxes it's not really a
percentage because as we said it's it's
a fixed amount that you could you would
only pay if you are working and could
afford it and what do you compare to the
fifty percent compared to that one coin
so people get a better yea though it
wouldn't even be a comparison you can't
go Saracen you can't compare them you so
well it did sometimes we have to also be
historically accurate sometimes they
increased it to four gold coins because
certain certain elements like for
example there was some friction or
wrongdoing from the other side and there
is a few exceptions in history where for
example someone misuse this law to get
that as we say these are the exceptions
huios in every time and in every place
we're going to find people who are the
exception they don't follow the law they
do it wrong they use it or they use
Islamic law for their own game and we
have to be fair I mentioned that this
did happen okay so when you read history
know about it but we should not actually
say put the microscope and then I try to
make that all Muslims throughout history
every time that's the defense of the
Muslim yes that's what happens sometimes
we choose certain bad parts of history
and everyone has bad parts of mystery
and we try to or the media tries to
highlight those parts let's hold it
right there when you write back for more
here an occasional is the lien coming to
the truth requires two things that
requires deep thinking that you've
already done but it requires another
step and that's courage if you have the
truth but you don't have courage you
won't stand up for the truth and that's
as good as standing up for falsehood
with day I would say this thing that
you're just told me it's not in the
scripture and they would say a marginal
note added by scribe yeah okay we know
that and I'd be thinking if you know
this is not the Bible why are you
preaching it as if it's gospel truth I
am not afraid to stand alone if allies
by my side I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand he's been
to you welcome back to the Dean show and
we're talking and giving a live
historical example of when God's law
chidiya the same way Shariah was
implemented during other prophets times
now you have it here Islam also which is
the call to apart piece by submitting to
the one guy submitting your will to the
will of the creator of the heavens and
earth and we're showing the justice
we're showing that the tax was
eradicated and now we mentioned earlier
the contrast between the two you had
rape of women you had crime people were
scared because the criminals are out
what happens now when Islam takes over
yes when the Muslims took over
eventually we'll see first that one of
the things is once they did this model
of applying the shower laude the news is
front about how fair they were treating
people and everything that to the point
that they were able to the two they were
able to easily go from village to
village and have a presence there and in
three and a half years all of Spain was
under Muslim rule and just within about
15 to 17 years the vast majority
of Spanish people who are living at that
time there they accepted Islam and
that's how it became many of them we
will see the soldiers the number of them
who initially came was for 7000 and then
12,000 and it was about 30,000 but
people accepted Islam in masses who were
living in voluntarily voluntarily and
under no coercion that's true and the
only part that was left because it was
surrounded by the mountains was the
Basque region and the north so because
why they saw the matters of the Muslims
and they saw that the soldiers were
there to protect them not to steal from
them not to rape their women they have
never seen anything like this and even
that's what they there's a something
they said when they went to report to
the Spanish king they said we've seen
people that are almost like people who
came from the sky what why did they say
this because they saw them normally at
that time around the world when a new
nation comes they are trying to take
over by force to steal the money to
steal the land the Muslims did not do
any of this they came and he said it to
them what would he want anything we just
come here to let you know about the
religion of God and whether you accept
it or not and then they spread the peace
and this is this was something common to
the Muslims even at the same time frame
Egypt was under the occupation of the
Roman Empire and there were the Roman
Empire was taking all the resources of
Egypt when the Muslim came on the
Muslims came they defeated the Roman
Empire and so the Egypt would in a few
years also became the vast majority of
them became Muslim because they the
Muslim safe and they didn't use their
resources and they didn't identities
their resources and at the same time
they the Egyptians were there were able
to flourish under the Islamic bomb and
they have that type of protection so the
handle of the drums was about to rob the
village rape this is
yes not to steal the liar not to steal
the money not to read it was for the
spreading of the religious but as we
said not by force so you can accept the
look there is a creator and you just
wish it Milan yes that's true and when
they wanted to open a new region it was
when they were not able to give a tip
preach to people there because we saw
for example in abyssea or what we call
that time of habit around if you hear
over there that the muslims weren't
there and there was they were living
under a Christian King initially yet
they were there living peacefully and
they were able to give the message
peaceful to others but when other
nations at that time were a purse like
Egypt was impressed by the Roman Empire
and the Spanish people was also a
prescriber King that's when the Muslims
are not able to tell people about the
religious so they have to and they have
to go and defeat those forces are taking
the resources of people save them and
then at that time people would have the
choice and they would live under the
piece of Islamic phone so much simple
but you know what people are getting rid
understand you almost only have a couple
more minutes tell us another few of the
many things were saying everyone else
wasn't it and inventions was somewhere
at the top mechanical science inventions
what other things yes inspires and
inventions to the point that even he
leads the kings of Europe at that time
there were some sending their children
for scholarships to study under the
Muslims in Spain and they have the
largest universities and the world over
there at the University of Cordoba over
there and Cordova had the second largest
library in the world after that that was
the capital of this line
the Abbasid Caliphate and what about
they had five thousand five hundred
thousand books at that time when the
largest at that time it was recorded and
this is again in none of some sources
you could check this but the largest
library here but that time was it all
had about two dozen of books not more
than thirty something so he and at that
time the trade of books has flourished
through the Muslims that they were also
getting the paper and they were right
they were translating all the sciences
from all over the world but then they
built on it and then Europe built again
their Renaissance based on what the
Muslims have achieved at that time you
some religions they were leading in size
yes they were leaving and it was also a
chance for four scientists from other
religions to flourish under Muslim lobby
or another prosecutor they were not
killed as long as they have the freedom
to explore any topic as long as there is
no blasphemy against God and this is
something we have to this is expected
because he's our Creator and we have to
respect a lot panel galleria a lot of
glorified but other than that they were
able to explore in any field of science
and they can do other things through
delayed untuk this there's no there is
no cut on the freedom of speech and this
is they want to talk and have a dialogue
between the Muslims about the religion
that was there was this freedom and we
could check out this the best way to
check this is through the book status or
right from them so you also are doing a
course this hell of us in the last 20
seconds tell our laws because you just
want to give them a taste people who
verifies you can also take you because
yes absolutely in this course we're
trying to show intensively in 16 hours
about give them a flavor of that history
of the golden image and what happened
and also at the same time we will admit
that there's also mistakes and we want
to
from these mistakes so that we don't do
them again we're trying to for people
who can't go to see we try to bring say
to them so they will get to see with
shocks of all of these places that
remain from the muslims and how they
live even till today some of the
technology they blew something up like
the water canals there's so difficult is
real you'll be able to see them between
the trees the how the water goes and
that's just one example of it and then
if allah wills this will be produced in
a book by next year and people could
also get this book through our website
thank you very much thank you lord tell
ready to thank you very much and thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
the Dean show and thank you for
listening we gave you an example when
Islam the call to acquire peace by
submitting to the owner if he's the one
who created you the one God people were
living in peace Jews Christians and
Muslims and you can go verified as check
this up and do the right thing if you're
looking for guidance and you like what
we have to say ask the one who created
you him alone to guide you and even if
you feel you know what it's not time for
me to submit I want to do my own thing
at least you got to understand us a
little bit better you can always reach
us at 1 866 to Islam to learn more and
we'll hopefully see you back next time
here again on adentro until then peace
be unto you